Before I talk more about cloud
computing, I'd like to illustrate
the opportunities that it delivers
with an example based on Animoto.
This is an example service.
And this was a poster child of cloud
computing in early years, around 2008,
2009.
This example that I'll describe next is
repeatedly referenced in cloud computing
talks, again, especially in
those early introductory years.
In the mid 2000's, Amazon was already
a dominant online retailer servicing
large volumes of online
sales transactions.
Vast majority of these transactions
were taking place during the US
holiday shopping season between
Thanksgiving and Christmas.
And to deal with this peak load, Amazon
provisioned the hardware resources, so
made sure that they've acquired
sufficient number of servers for
this particular load.
What that means is that the rest of the
year a lot of these resources were idle.
Or they were serviced for other company
tasks, for instance, forecasting or
other analytics.
But regardless,
there were still a lot of idle cycles.
Now, since Amazon had already
developed some software infrastructure
to allow these machines
to be reprovisioned and
used by other services
within the company.
What they ended up doing in 2006,
they opened up those exact same type
of API's to the rest of the world.
What this did,
it allowed third party work load.
So not just Amazon work loads,
but completely random customers
to run their workloads on Amazon's
hardware, obviously, for a fee.
This was the birth of
Amazon's Web Services, or AWS, and
Amazon's Elastic Compute Cloud, or EC2.
One of the companies that appeared
around the same time as Amazon's EC2
cloud was Animoto.
Some of you may have used the service.
It turns an album of
pictures into a video.
And although this sounds simple,
it's a fairly compute intensive job
that involves a lot of
image processing steps so
that the video appears
as smooth as possible.
So they decided to focus their resources
on the development of the mechanisms
that make better videos.
And instead of buying and
running their own equipment,
they chose to rent some of the web
provided computer infrastructure that
was part of Amazon's compute cloud.
The company was doing okay, and
it had a relatively steady work load
which required about 50 of these
Amazon's compute instances.
Now these are not physical servers,
instead they were virtual machines.
They had no control over exactly how
Amazon runs these virtual machines,
whether they are on the same physical
server or many other physical servers.
Then, in April 2008, Animoto became
available on the Facebook platform.
What it means is that it became an
option available to Facebook users with
a click of a button to turn
their timeline photos or
albums into cool video.
What happened afterwards was
the definition of going viral.
Within 3 days,
Animoto signed up 750,000 new users.
And from the 50 compute instances, so
the 50 machines that
it needed on Monday.
That number became 400 by Tuesday.
So an order of magnitude
larger in a day.
And then by the end of that week,
by Friday,
that number of machines was 3,400.
Two orders of magnitude increase in
the resources, just within that week,
just within those four or five days.
There's no way they could have been able
to respond to this dramatic increase in
demand if they had gone with
a traditional route of owning and
managing their own infrastructure.
You just would not be able to bring in,
install, wire,
configure, et cetera,
as many machines in such a short time.
Even if by some miracle they actually
did have the physical space and
could fit all of these machines
in the machine room, and
then that there was sufficient
power to power all that.
The only reason that Animoto
was able to do this is because
they used a cloud-based deployment and
then they leveraged the capabilities
that cloud computing offers.